this has been quite a week for you it's
like
like obviously like nothing you've ever
experienced how are you
keeping it all together right now um
just taking it
taking everything as it comes and just
carrying on
doing what i'm doing and um now the
team around me is helping um and doing
everything they can to help me so
that's it's just taking every day as it
comes and enjoying every moment
yeah that's very cool this is as someone
who's been
uh writing music for a while and putting
up music on social media and sharing it
even before this happened is this like
the
is this like the perfect dream of what
sharing music on social media
can do definitely definitely this is um
this just kind of shows you what what
your social media and your all your big
platforms can do it's like
you never know when it's going to happen
and it could always just be right around
the corner so
like um if else anybody who's like
aspiring and be a musician or an artist
just keep going because you never know
what's in the corner
um it's funny because like
before i even logged on this morning
to check even my work mail first thing i
was humming your tune
like it's just a thing that right like
it's
become so ubiquitous what is the most
surprising way that you've seen it be
shared i know the andrew lloyd webber
one was pretty wild
and it's just seeing there was there was
a video made
and where somebody had took like so many
duets
from tiktok and put them all into the
one big video
and it synced them all up so that they
were all on time and they were all
perfect and it was just amazing it was
like one big massive
c shiny choir it was fantastic
obviously you're not getting out too
much but when you do
you know get outside of your home um are
people
recognizing you now is that a weird
thing yeah those are
um there's a few people recognizing me
on the street now um
that's when that's with my mask on and
my heart on so
still recognizing me so i i think it's
only gonna
it's only gonna get more and more from
from now on
it's great and how have your family and
friends reacted to all this
yeah they've been absolutely buzzing and
so supportive
they're loving every minute of it and
because they're they're watching from
the outside and they're watching it all
happen watching it all unfold
there they are absolutely just loving
every minute
and now you're assigned to a major label
walk me through like your uh your
reaction
to this happening like how did it happen
did they reach out to you like what was
the deal
and so it all kind of just happened over
pretty much
a weekend um so it went from the tick
tock just being a tech talk
and then a week later 220 kid and bill
and ted had made like a small remix
from the tick tock video and put on
their socials
and that went crazy radio stations then
took it and wanted to play it
and and then at this point polydor got
in touch and and other record labels
were in touch as well but
um after getting to talking to britney
head and valentine
and polydor we just decided well it's
it's really good so let's why not make
it a real thing
and make it a proper a proper track so
then it just came out it
just went from there and all the pieces
kind of just fell together
nice and so what's the plan now what's
you know i've seen
a lot of the music that you shared on
instagram before this became huge
are you thinking of releasing a lot of
that stuff that you've already written
like are you writing new things all the
time now
what's the plan for what's up yes i'm
always trying to um
i've not had i've not had much time the
last week or two but
i've always been trying to write new
music in and just trying to come up with
new ideas and new things
and so
see that then then that's what we'll
need to do we'll do that
you've said that um lewis capaldi and
derma kennedy are two of your
big influences uh what is it about those
two that inspires you
and it's it's the storytelling and the
songwriting
uh and dan mckennady especially he kind
of
he's the perfect example for me because
he can kind of go from
playing a guitar and just singing a long
acoustic and and
it'd be absolutely amazing but then he
can also go and do
like a dance track with meduza or
somebody else and he does
like edm music as well and he can kinda
and apply me the two types of music and
it's it's just
shows how very versatile he is and i
feel like
i feel like i could fight fit the same
uh i think one of my favorite tracks of
yours that i saw on youtube
was you talking about what is like
internet dating
and like trying to like okay
uh has that changed for you now are you
i have people messaging you now and now
that you're uh uh
you know now that you've gotten on um
yeah there's definitely people mailing
me but um i've been married for a year
and a half now so um
the wife's kind of like hey looking over
my shoulder
no no she's fine it's just them i just
need to keep telling everybody
listen back off
that's awesome with all this happening
and uh
people you know so many people paying
attention now there's all these doors
that are open
so you sort of got the attention of the
world
if you could reach out to anyone and say
you know
i would love to work with you i'd like
to get in the room with you or resume
with you who would it be
it would be either one of the two they
are solus capability kermit kennedy or
ed sheeran ed sheeran is probably
number one but um anyone in e3 and i
would be
ecstatic when you go
through your um your comments and people
that are
uh liking and sharing you know the sea
shanty
are you getting a lot of support from
people too for whatever kind of music
you do or is it more people that are
just focused on oh i want to hear more
of that no i like what i like
a lot about the attention that has been
coming my way and people on tick tock
and stuff
is they're also going back and checking
my other stuff as well and the comments
under them have been absolutely
fantastic
and at the same time so no it's it's
good that the seashells are getting
attention and that's what kind of put me
in the position i'm i know but
um yeah people people like mother stuff
as well which i'm i'm very very grateful
for
yeah but i mean the sea shanty thing
it's a it's a great sound
and um obviously it's caught on what do
you
what was it about it that made you
initially want to share it in the first
place
it was basically i'd been uploading a
tech talk since
january and it was just i was taking
suggestions in the comments
and somebody had said could you do a c
shiny it's a bit different it's called
leave hog johnny could you do that
so i just i went away and uh and i've
done some research
and came back and yeah i just uploaded
leaf of johnny
and everyone loved it and and then
that's when people were
suggesting the drunken sailor the
scotsman
the wellerman so then i just kind of i
can added them in a list and
i got around to them in december yeah
nice
and among all the people that have um
reached out to you or commented who
would surprise you most
that you found out as a fan of yours
um just just the duets and stuff
and the the um like seeing andrew lloyd
whoever drew it and then
seeing gary barlow and roman and keaton
and doing a sea
danny on this tech talk as well it's
just seeing things like that i'm just
like this is amazing
and the amount of the amount of smells
it's putting in people's faces it's
incredible
and what do you want to you know if
you're looking five years down the road
ten years down the road and it and i was
like
this week has been a lot right now but
when you have the time to sit down and
go okay i can think about what i want
this to look like in the future what do
you want to look at in the future
um just a decent fan base and
and hopefully we can continue making
music and hopefully have a few albums
out
and um making music that that that
people love and
and i'm proud of us that's all i look
forward to
nice does your wife sing also no she
doesn't she doesn't and she's just
she just gets sick of me listening
she must be emboldened at this point now
that i'm all over the australian
all over the radio and she must be
everything's on mute
that's amazing you gotta gotta get her
on the track someday somehow
i know that's that maybe graduate
right on man well pleasure to meet you
uh congratulations on
everything i'm really looking forward to
what comes back for you
thank you so much thank you take care